[Music]
on this wednesday night alberta's
coveted crisis and political turmoil
as health care workers work to save
lives the premier fights for his
political future the voices calling for
jason kenny's resignation or growing is
a leadership review coming
ontario's vaccine passports are now in
effect the system crash and the
criticism what i'm asking this premier
to do is fix the holes in his vaccine
certificate program not guilty on all 38
charges the reasons for the verdict in
the case of an ottawa bus driver and a
deadly crash
and he towers over everyone i just love
it the canadian boy who is the world's
tallest teenager
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight in alberta where the
pandemic is raging and the premier is
fighting for his political future jason
kenney widely criticized for his
handling of the pandemic is taking heat
from all sides including within his own
party leadership did come up during a
caucus meeting today though there was no
vote of confidence on kenny's leadership
this is what alberta's hospitals are
grappling with icus are filled with
covet 19 patients and exhausted staff
are struggling to keep up there are now
more than 1 000 albertans with covid19
19 in the hospital most non-urgent
surgeries have been postponed and more
icu beds have been added to help keep up
without those extra beds the province
says its icus would be at
174 percent capacity
alberta reported 20 more deaths from
covid19 today one of them was an 18 year
old the youngest albertan to die from
the virus heather urex west has our top
story tonight on the pandemic and the
political turmoil and fears a change in
leadership now might actually make
things worse
alberta's intensive care units have
never seen so many patients
or so much
want it to be death
is there anyone that we need to call in
this video taken last week at calgary's
peter lawhead center another patient is
intubated there are now more than 300
patients in icus across alberta the
normal number of beds is 173.
as the dam burst
i
i would kind of worry to some extent it
has i mean you know there's talk about
triage but obviously you know we've
canceled a lot of elective surgeries and
i think that would be
the sign that maybe the canary has died
health care workers are doing everything
they can to avoid triage protocols
nobody wants to get to a point where a
panel makes decisions on who will live
and die
but with space inside the province
waning alberta has asked the military to
help our planning includes a potential
aeromedical evacuation capability from
the canadian armed forces including
getting more personnel skilled in
patient management and transfers that
can help support relocating patients uh
to hospitals outside of the province if
needed the alberta government has been
heavily criticized by the medical
community for acting too late to control
the delta fueled fourth wave but within
jason kenney's government there has also
been fierce opposition to the province
taking any action at all these different
factions don't seem to be agree be able
to agree on a very on very much with
respect to
to
covet management policy but they do seem
to agree that jason kennedy should be
gone on wednesday the alberta government
caucus met to discuss kenny's leadership
through the covitt crisis the premier
has said he will be accountable to his
party when there is a leadership review
but when and if kenny loses the support
of the party who would take over there
are people that are concerned if jason
kenney isn't at the helm
vaccine passports and restrictions and
federal help may all be in jeopardy
political chaos behind the largest
public health crisis alberta has ever
seen one that has killed more than 200
people in the last three weeks alone and
there is still no sign the fourth wave
here has reached its peak heather urex
west global news calgary
covent case counts are on the decline in
ontario and premier doug ford hopes to
keep it that way the new vaccine
passport system came into effect there
today people have to prove their
vaccination status to enter public
places such as restaurants bars gyms and
movie theaters the premier who initially
opposed vaccine passports now says
they're the best way to avoid another
lockdown jamie morocco reports
flashing vaccine credentials for a cup
of joe
it's now just another part of the
morning routine for many ontarians i'm
willing to do it if it helps to you know
reduce the number of like sick people
and help to like get back to normal
faster but for some business owners the
province's vaccine passport program is
slowing things down and obviously all it
really takes is a couple people to have
to like search through their whole email
inbox
before the line gets really backed up
ontario's government has plans to launch
an app for employers to quickly scan
vaccine information through a qr code
but it won't be ready until late october
right now a pdf copy has to be
downloaded off the provincial portal to
print or store on your phone we should
have already had the passport and been
ready for the first day online the
scramble to access vaccination records
caused the system to crash and what i'm
asking this premier to do is fix the
holes in his vaccine certificate program
ontario's official opposition also has
concerns around enforcement and
retailers such as malls being left off
the mandate's list
[Music]
at toronto's st lawrence market where
you can typically shop and enjoy a meal
tables were blocked off we were told
somehow that because they were not
checking for the vaccine passports
it was more prudent not to eat inside
premier doug ford says he followed cues
from ontario's top doctor on where proof
of vaccination would help most still
sore about having to enact the policy at
all he doesn't plan on vac's passports
lasting forever i don't want to do it a
day longer than we have to but he isn't
ready to announce an end date
for employers and canadians across so
many provinces like with so much in this
pandemic it means being flexible it's
not invasive to care about the people
that you're you know putting at risk a
means to an end to get more people
vaccinated and keep those who can't safe
jamie rocker global news toronto
new brunswick's vaccine passport system
also took effect this morning full
vaccination is now required for anyone
12 and older who wants to eat inside a
restaurant or get into nightclubs gyms
and other non-essential venues masks are
also mandatory in all public indoor
spaces and anyone entering new brunswick
must now pre-register with the province
canada will begin allowing direct
flights from india again starting on
monday the ban on direct commercial and
private passenger flights expires
september 26th travelers will need to
have a negative coveted test result
taken within 18 hours of departure from
india the flight ban was put in place in
april because of the rapid spread of the
delta variant the rate of daily new
cases in india has declined by 92
percent since then
now to the aftermath of the federal
election the liberals will form a
minority government despite receiving a
smaller percentage of the popular vote
than the conservatives the popular vote
is worth looking into the people's party
of canada for example didn't win any
seats but an estimated 820 000 canadians
voted for them that's five percent of
the popular vote and more than twice the
number who voted for the green party
the ppc finished second in eight ridings
and as our chief political correspondent
david aiken explains their support came
from both the right and the left
[Applause]
angry protesters at justin trudeau
rallies many from the people's party of
canada or the ppc and conservatives were
clearly worried the ppc was stealing
their votes justin trudeau wants you to
split the vote
by voting ppc
he wants you to let him
get away with it the conservatives did
bleed some support to the ppc but not as
much as you might think it's not
necessarily fair to say that all of the
votes that were gathered by the ppc
would have been conservative votes
indeed internal conservative poll said
as many as 25 percent of ppc voters this
year cast a ballot in 2019 for the green
party and like many green voters the ppc
vote was seen as a protest vote there's
a significant number of people who are
voting for the the
people's party this time around just as
there is for the greens who are really
none of the above voters so it's really
a an odd coalition of different types of
voters not all of whom would have ended
up voting conservative the ppc platform
this year was the same as 2019
anti-immigrant anti-foreign aid anti-cbc
and so on but the galvanizing force this
year was opposition to public health
restrictions and their target was not
just justin trudeau but anyone in power
we have seen anti-vaccine anti-mask
anti-covet restrictions for a year and a
half across this province against all
elected leaders against doug ford
against jason kennedy against brian
pallaster there's a bit of an
anti-system anti-institutional vote
going on there that wouldn't have
necessarily come out for the
conservatives particularly
particularly this time around the big
question for the country's political
class if there was no pandemic would
eight hundred thousand canadians have
voted for the ppc
pollsters and political scientists say
probably not but so long as there are
public health restrictions expect those
who object to those restrictions to find
their political voice in movements like
the ppc donna okay david aiken in ottawa
thank you
the driver of a transit bus involved in
a fatal crash in ottawa two years ago
has been found not guilty of all
criminal charges isito diallo was
charged with three counts of dangerous
driving causing death and 35 counts of
dangerous driving causing bodily harm
she was behind the wheel of a
double-decker transit bus that slammed
into the metal awning of a bus station
in january 2019 three people were killed
dozens of others severely injured in his
ruling justice matthew weber said
diallo's driving merited scrutiny but
said the setting sun was an obvious
hazard at the time and there was an
errant marking on the road that led her
directly into a snow-filled gutter he
called the case tragic and acknowledged
the degree of human pain and loss
on the canary islands coming up the
volcanic lava swallowing up homes
and disturbing allegations about how u.s
border agents treated haitian migrants
the us government is promising a swift
investigation into what appears to be
mistreatment of haitian migrants along
its border with mexico border agents on
horseback chased people down and a
warning some of the images are
disturbing
the video shows border patrol agents
chasing migrants and using the reins of
their horses to whip some of them trying
to stop them from crossing the rio
grande into texas up to 14 000 haitians
hoping to seek asylum in the u.s are
camped near the border where there's
little food and water and temperatures
have reached 40 degrees celsius
the images
that
emanated from
del rio
texas over the last several days
and correctly and necessarily
were met with uh our nation's horror
because they do not reflect who we are
as a country we are addressing this with
tremendous speed and with tremendous
force
earlier this week the biden
administration began deporting hundreds
of migrants to haiti many of them have
not lived in their home country for
years and they're returning to turmoil
haiti is recovering from a devastating
earthquake last month and the political
crisis after the assassination of its
president in july
the u.s president joe biden is calling
on wealthy nations to do more to respond
to the pandemic
we're not going to solve this crisis
with half measures or middle of the road
ambitions we need to go big
and we need to do our part
at a virtual covit 19 summit today he
pledged the u.s would share one billion
pfizer biontech vaccine doses the goal
is to vaccinate 70 percent of the global
population within the next year but in
america itself where vaccination rates
have stalled in some states an average
of 2 000 people a day are now dying
jackson proskow reports
it didn't have to be like this the worst
days of the pandemic more patience and
more deaths arriving after vaccines
became available we've been shouting
from the rooftops for a long time now
how bad this is and what this can do
and to watch it despite your your your
warnings and your your pleadings
to just come through and take life like
it does that that's hard in state after
state doctors and nurses are stretched
to the breaking point some have no beds
left to offer others have run out of
nurses to staff them it's estimated that
there were additional 300 000
hospitalizations in the u.s this summer
that were totally preventable if more
people had been vaccinated facing the
overwhelming surge hospitals in states
like idaho are prepared to ration care
using crisis standards to decide who
gets treatment even non-coveted patients
may find there are no beds available if
they need them we've heard stories about
heart attack patients from texas being
flown eventually to sacramento
california to get care
more americans have now died from covid
than the 1918 flu pandemic
679 thousand marked at this haunting
memorial in washington the u.s has
become a cautionary tale this is an all
hands on deck crisis but is trying to
serve as a global example during a
vaccine summit with prime minister
justin trudeau and other leaders
president joe biden announced a plan to
ship 1.1 billion doses to low-income
countries that are desperate for the
vaccines so many americans seem to take
for granted for every one shot we've
administered to date in america we have
now committed to do three shots to the
rest of the world at the same time the
u.s is weighing whether to give more
doses to americans on thursday the cdc
will decide on booster shots potentially
offering a third dose at a time when
many are still rejecting their first
donna jackson prosco in washington thank
you the uk is reportedly considering
trying to join the existing trade deal
between canada mexico and the united
states british prime minister boris
johnson admitted today the trade deal he
promised with the u.s is off the table
for now johnson is in washington meeting
with u.s president joe biden and other
congressional leaders
the biden administration is not doing
free trade deals
around the world right now but i've got
absolutely every confidence that a great
deal is there to be done and there are
plenty of people in that building behind
me who certainly want to do one
the uk already has trade deals of its
own with mexico and canada and back in
2017 johnson said the uk would be first
in line for a post-brexit trade deal
with the united states
under taliban rule still ahead a former
afghan governor fears for the future of
women in her country
you're watching global national
[Music]
a volcanic eruption has thousands of
people on the move in spain's canary
islands walls of molten lava have
swallowed nearly 200 homes since the
combre valleja volcano erupted on sunday
the first time it's come to life in 50
years residents on the island of la
palma are scrambling to pack up their
belongings and leave there are also
concerns all that molten lava could
release dangerous gases once it reaches
the atlantic ocean scientists warn the
eruption could continue for weeks or
even months
australia's second largest city has been
hit by a powerful earthquake several
buildings in melbourne were damaged and
power lines came down onto the street
the magnitude 5.9 quake one of the
country's strongest on record struck
northeast of the city tremors were felt
though as far north as sydney there are
no reports of serious injuries
very passionate
i've just been struck in the back of a
backpack of a head and that's an
australian journalist who got caught up
in violent demonstrations against
pandemic restrictions and vaccination
rules in melbourne thousands of people
faced off with riot police protesters
are angry about lockdown measures and a
new vaccine mandate that requires
construction workers to show proof of at
least one dose by thursday more than 200
people were arrested it is the third
consecutive day of demonstrations there
in afghanistan the worst fears are
coming true for women and girls girls
age 12 and up are no longer allowed to
go to school most women are prevented
from going to work the ministry of
women's affairs has been abolished by
the taliban and women have no voice in
the new government our crystal
commansing spoke with a woman who once
served as a governor in afghanistan
about what lies ahead
this is really unfortunate and i am the
life
witness hamiva sarobi has lived through
all of the twists and turns of
afghanistan's turbulent history she
served as a minister under former afghan
president hamid karzai and was appointed
the country's first female governor
she also remembers what it was like when
the taliban was first in power in 1996
and she wasn't allowed at the table i
couldn't stay in kabul that i thought
that maybe my
my children will be out of education and
my daughter will be illiterate so i went
to pakistan as an immigrant
once again those who are able are
seeking refuge across the border in
pakistan sarobi eventually returned to
her country in 2001 and was able to help
transform her community
but now she fears the younger generation
will find it even harder than she did
because their ambitions are so much
greater for example my daughter now my
daughter that on the first time that
when taliban came
she was on the 5th grade now
now she is with two master degrees the
other son is my son is medical doctor
the other one is the architecture how
they can
accept that taliban could push them back
to stay at home do nothing
the taliban has said that women can work
just not anywhere men are present we
have fought
for almost uh
40 years
to
bring a sharia law system in our
government
sharia law does not allow women
and men get together or sit together
under one roof when i face increasing
restrictions the united nations chief of
human rights recently expressed concern
that the taliban stated commitments
aren't matching realities on the ground
getting the new government to uphold
international treaties says sorobi will
be up to countries such as qatar iran
and pakistan because they have clout
with the taliban to be honest we we have
gone back 50 years
50 years
speaking to global news from her home in
turkey sirobi says the road ahead will
be a test of strength especially for
young people in large cities
who have grown up with western freedoms
crystal gomansing global news
london
well kids grow up fast but this is off
the charts next meet the world's tallest
teen
this teenager from montreal is reaching
new heights his name is olivier ryu and
it's impossible to miss him on the
basketball court or anywhere really at
age 15 he is a little over seven feet
five inches tall he towers over his
whole family and his shoe size is 20. is
that even a thing his height has earned
him a place in the guinness book of
world records as the tallest male teen
in the world something he says he was
aspiring to since he was little
i see a page that
is the tallest
teenager and
he wasn't
tall as me so i was like oh maybe i can
get it and i get it
he says his next dream is to play in the
nba
i'm sure you've got their attention
olivier that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
here canada is this gaggle of geese
invading a downtown vancouver
intersection we'd love to see your
canada please email it to us and thanks
for watching for our nasa will be here
tomorrow and i'll see you next week bye